my name is Sarah Boland I'm the events
director here at Kramer books and on
behalf of the entire staff I'm so
pleased to welcome you and I'm really
pleased to welcome Bruce tonight for his
book
JFK's forgotten crisis in the book
Bruce shares the gripping story of the
conflict that really has escaped
history's attention but it really still
resonates today it's that of the
sino-indian war he draws on newly
declassified documents and details the
decisions made by JFK to stem the tide
of an all-out war and explains how this
forgotten crisis is still influencing
the world more than half a century later
we're so glad that he's here with us to
share his new book please join me in
welcoming Bruce Riedel to Primmer books
[Applause]
that's good I think thank you very much
Sarah for that introduction and thank
all of you for coming out tonight I want
to begin by taking you back a half a
century on the morning of October 16th
1962 McGeorge Bundy John F Kennedy is
national security adviser arrived at his
office in the West Wing of the White
House on his desk as there was every
morning there was a file prepared by the
White House Situation Room of the most
important top-secret documents that he
had to see before he saw the president
that day two documents were notably
important on the 16th of October one was
a memo from the State Department from
the Bureau of intelligence and research
and in that document the State
Department warned that the situation
between China and India on their border
in the Himalaya Mountains was
deteriorating rapidly and that there was
a very good chance that a war was going
to break out between China and India the
document also warned the president that
if that happened India would probably be
the loser and that the United States
might be called upon by India's Prime
Minister Nehru to provide assistance and
support to stem the Chinese invasion it
also warned him that if he did provide
support to India
that would alienate our ally in South
Asia Pakistan and could lead to a crisis
in us-pakistani relations the other
document that morning was a report from
the Central Intelligence Agency and in
it it summarized the result of a recent
YouTube overflight of the island of Cuba
the CIA had discovered just today before
that the Soviet Union was in the process
of putting intermediate-range ballistic
missiles in Cuba which had the capacity
to hit almost every American city east
of the Mississippi River it was a global
game changer by the Soviets in
retrospect one of these crises is well
known we've all seen movies about the
Cuban Missile Crisis we've seen books
about the Cuban Missile Crisis there's a
whole industry of studies about the
Cuban Missile Crisis and there should be
the Cuban Missile Crisis was the closest
we came to Armageddon in the Cold War
John F Kennedy was dealing with an issue
which if he dealt with it wrong would
have meant we wouldn't be here today the
apocalypse would have occurred in fact
we now know 50 years later that it was
even more dangerous than people thought
it was then the CIA back in 1962
estimated there were six to eight
thousand Soviet soldiers on the island
in fact there were 50,000 Soviet
soldiers on the island the CIA thought
that the Soviets had only brought into
intermediate-range ballistic missiles in
fact the Russians had also brought with
them tactical nuclear weapons and they'd
surrounded the Guantanamo Naval Base
with what were called frog missiles and
the commander of the Soviet forces on
the island had the authority already
delivered from Moscow that when the
first American bomb dropped on Cuba he
could fire a salvo of tactical nuclear
weapons into the Guantanamo Naval Base
where there were 5,000 Marines
but just as that crisis was so important
it shouldn't completely overlook the
other crisis the sino-indian war China
and India are the world's two biggest
countries by virtue of population and
back in the 1960s they were the cutting
edge of a competition between democracy
and communism in many ways they were
where the whole Cold War was really
going to be fought out and Kennedy had
actually campaigned in 1959 in 1960 one
of the planks that he campaigned on was
the United States wanted India to win
this competition the State Department
memo was remarkably prescient they got
it absolutely right a few days later the
war degan and the Chinese immediately
began over running the front line Indian
positions within a week or two India was
in a very serious very serious position
and looked like it was going to be
defeated Nehru as the State Department
predicted did very very reluctantly
asked the United States and the United
Kingdom for assistance and by the end of
October 1962 the United States and the
Royal Air Force were flying a massive
airlift of weapons and equipment in
India six 707s were landing every day at
New Delhi International Airport and from
there
American c-130s were taking equipment to
the frontlines in the Himalayas and in
Kashmir then the Chinese stopped they
paused for a week and then they started
again with an even larger offensive at
the end of November this offensive
threatened to overrun all of eastern
India if you think of India there's that
little neck part that sticks out beyond
Bangladesh Bangladesh of course in 1962
was East Pakistan all of that part
looked like it was going to fall into
Chinese hands and it was unclear whether
the Chinese would stop there there were
some in India who thought the Chinese
would march all the way to Calcutta and
take India's second largest city
on November 19th 1962 the crisis came to
its head Nehru sent to Kennedy two
letters the first letter arrived just
before a National Security Council
meeting the second letter arrived during
the meeting but the American ambassador
in New Delhi John Kenneth Galbraith and
I'll come back to him in a minute
had already previewed the second letter
the second letter was a cry for
immediate assistance in it Nehru said we
are on the verge of going under the
whole world is going to see a communist
giant march into a democracy and destroy
it I'm not sure India will survive this
catastrophe and then he came to the
punchline he said he immediately needed
12 squadrons of American combat fighter
aircraft with American pilots and two
more squadrons of American bombers to be
snatched immediately to India to join in
the war in this letter Nehru was asking
the president the United States for 350
combat aircraft to be deployed
immediately into India to defend Indian
airspace while India began bombing raids
into Tibet
it was obviously going to be a slippery
slope once we went into India we were
going to be at war with Communist China
the president that night decided that he
needed time he couldn't make this
decision overnight and he did two things
first he dispatched a US Navy carrier
battle group to the Bay of Bengal in
order to demonstrate American support
for India secondly he sent Averell
Harriman on an urgent mission left
actually left that night from Andrews
Air Force Base to fly direct to India to
assess India's needs at the time
Averell Harriman is not well remembered
today but he's an icon of American
diplomacy
Averell Harriman is the man that
Franklin Delano Roosevelt sent to London
during the Blitz to assess whether the
we're gonna survive the Nazi onslaught
he's the man FDR sent to Moscow in 1941
to see whether the Soviet Union was
going to be able to survive the Nazi
invasion this was the biggest big gun
that you could possibly find anywhere he
did something else as well and he'd been
doing it forever in the beginning of the
crisis he sent another message to
Pakistan saying don't even think about
it because from the beginning of the
crisis the Pakistani military dictator
Ayub Khan had been sending signals that
a he was very unhappy America was
supporting India and B he therefore
wanted to be compensated as he liked to
say for Pakistan's neutrality and
compensation meant give me Kashmir
Kennedy refused to give in to this
blackmail and he sent repeated messages
to the Pakistanis that if you enter this
war we will regard you as part of the
enemy not as part of the alliance that
we have with you the 20th of November
was sheer panic in New Delhi John
Kenneth Galbraith writes in his memoirs
that it looked like India was going to
disintegrate all Indian aircraft private
and public were commissioned
commissioned by the Indian Air Force
martial law was declared in much of
northeast India and India belatedly
began moving troops from the Pakistan
front even though it feared a second
front could open up and then that night
for no reclamation China unilaterally
stopped the Chinese ceased their
offensive and announced that within a
month they would draw back to the lines
where they had started we don't know why
China did that Chinese records are not
available today you can get a lot of
records about what the American
government thought about what the Indian
government thought but Chinese archives
remain sealed Nehru credited John F
Kennedy with convincing the Chinese to
stop he told John Kenneth
Galbraith that it was America's resolve
and Kennedy's determination not to let
the Chinese win manifested in the
airlift and manifested in the deployment
of the aircraft carrier battle group
they're persuaded Beijing to stop and
not let this crisis continue to go any
further this of course leaves us with
the great what if what if the Chinese
hadn't stopped that night would the
United States have found itself at war
with Communist China
remember in 1962 it would only been nine
years before when we had been at war
with Communist China and Korea fought a
war in Korea with the Communist Chinese
for the better part of three years and
here Nehru was essentially asking us to
go to war with China again we'll never
know
it's a what-if but in my judgment
Kennedy almost certainly would have said
yes and I make that judgment for several
reasons first because he really did
believe that Indian democracy was
crucial to the United States in the
global balance of power second because
his ambassador John Kenneth Galbraith
who was a personal friend and one of the
people closest to the president would
almost certainly have recommended it and
third because just a year later in the
fall of 1963 the United States Air Force
the Royal Air Force and small squadrons
from the Royal Australian Air Force and
the Royal Canadian Air Force deployed
into India for a military training
exercise which was exactly what Nehru
had asked for a year before so we
actually practiced going into this war
the conflict between China and India
ended in a ceasefire unilaterally on the
21st of November 1962 but the conflicts
not over China and India have never
settled their border dispute this border
dispute remains the longest unsettled
border dispute in the world today
neither party agrees to wear that border
should be there have been hundreds of
meetings between the Chinese and Indians
and they haven't succeeded one iota
and moving forward they are big trading
partners with each other today the
likelihood of another China India war is
probably pretty low I wouldn't say the
same thing about the likelihood of
another india-pakistan war that I think
is probably a very serious reality so
that dispute continues to this day and
in addition that dispute has led to two
other things an access between China and
Pakistan China and Pakistan had barely
any interaction with each other before
1962 but if you look back in 50 years
perspective it's 1962 or the alliance
between China and Pakistan begins and
today that Alliance is very strong they
call it the all-weather alliance it's
kind of a snub at the United States
we're not all whether they are all
whether they say it's taller than the
Himalayas and deeper than the Indian
Ocean and just this year China and
Pakistan signed agreements which will
lead to 46 billion dollars in Chinese
investment in Pakistani infrastructure
and of course it heads another dimension
their secret nuclear collusion Pakistan
and China have been secret nuclear
partners since the 1960s China gave
Pakistan the designs for its nuclear
weapons force and today Pakistan has the
fastest growing a nuclear weapons
program in the world faster than any
other country this has also led to a
triangular
arms race probably the most dangerous
arms race in the world today between
China and Pakistan on the one hand and
India on the other just two years ago
India proudly announced that had fired
an intermediate-range ballistic missile
that allowed it for the first time to
target Beijing with nuclear weapons so
the crisis that was averted in 1962
remains a problem even to this day
john f kennedy's forgotten store crisis
is the story of that crisis mostly from
the American point of view it also has
several other backstories which I'd be
happy to talk about in Q&A like the role
played by the first lady who's very
important in this whole issue and the
role played by the CIA in trying to
sponsor a rebellion in Tibet but let me
just finish with one final word about
sources this book relies upon letters
that have only been Declassified in the
last couple of years between Kennedy and
Nehru for more than 50 years the Indian
government denied these letters even
existed
because in some ways they're very very
embarrassing India at its moment of
greatest need had to ask the United
States to bail it out the letters are
declassified and this is the first book
that takes advantage of looking at those
documents in depth with that thank you
very much for your attention and I'd be
delighted to take questions if I can
come up with answers
[Applause]
right John F Kennedy never went to India
and Pakistan during the thousand days
that he was in office he he had gone to
India in the early 1950s and mrs.
Kennedy actually recounts what happened
she didn't go with him but it's a great
anecdote she said that when the then
Senator John F Kennedy got to New Delhi
and they requested a meeting with the
Prime Minister the u.s. embassy told him
that the Prime Minister's attention
often failed pretty quickly and that if
the prime minister's attention was
failing he'd start to look up at the
ceiling and start playing with his
pencil within two minutes of the meeting
with John F Kennedy
according to Jacky Nehru was staring up
at the ceiling and playing with his
pencils so it was not a very auspicious
start for their relationship it got
better but mrs. Kennedy did travel to
South Asia during the thousand days of
the Kennedy administration she went in
the spring of 1962 so just a few months
before the crisis it was the first time
a first lady had traveled by herself
outside the United States in the age of
television Eleanor Roosevelt had
traveled during the Second World War but
there was no television and Truman and
Eisenhower wife's never traveled by
themselves overseas now when I say by
herself
that's a little bit of a misnomer her
sister went with her a Secret Service
detachment of about 25 people they had
they needed a Boeing 707 to get them
there as well her trip was a spectacular
success she was hailed as the queen of
America in India and Pakistan and she
excited the crowds not just in India and
Pakistan but because of television she
excited the people back in the United
States of America
in Pakistan a Yukon also gave her her
gift he'd heard that she was a horse
woman that she loved horses that she
loved riding that she loved jumping with
them so he gave her a ten year old
gelding named xodar the DAR means chief
in dari and she laid immediate
instructions back to the White House
that sadar was to be given VIP treatment
flown home on its air own airplane and
there was going to be nothing about
these silly rules about checking the
veterinary background to this horse was
to be shipped immediately to her farm
well it is the DAR that bride's
riderless behind john f kennedy's
caisson during the funeral of
Pennsylvania Avenue and over to
Arlington Park it's kind of a unique
reminder of the role india and pakistan
played in the in the kennedy
administration the other thing she did
of course was she was a hostess she
hosted both Ayub Khan and Nehru for
state visits to the United States the
state visit for field marshal Ayub Khan
was unique only once in American history
has Mount Vernon George Washington's
home been used for a state visit Jackie
wanted to use Mount Vernon she had just
come back from a trip with her husband
to Versailles in France and the
Schonbrunn palace in Austria but we
don't have any palaces but she wanted to
do something equally grand so in June
1961 Mount Vernon was the site of a very
special summit between Ayub Khan and
John F Kennedy a few months later Nehru
came it was in November and Nehru they
had now of course if you'd had Mount
Vernon for the Pakistani what do you do
to outdo that
so they took Nehru to Jackie's home in
Newport
Rhode Island Hammersmith farms it's
called a cottage but if you've ever
driven around Newport you'll realize
their idea of a cottage is a lot
different than most of us but it turned
out to be a complete failure nehru at
this point was getting on in age he was
very tired he was very exhausted from
the flight he answered most of Kennedy's
requests and most of Kennedy's thoughts
with mono syllabic short answers there
was no engagement and then it got worse
after the stop and Newport they came
down to the White House to have official
dinner in the White House as well and
somebody on the White House staff failed
to properly open the flue in the
fireplace in the East Room and the
meeting began with smoke spreading
throughout the White House was not a
very auspicious starting to their
relationship but mrs. Kennedy in this
regard was was it was a crucial partner
with her husband in the American
engagement with both India and Pakistan
in the early 1960s
yeah please document I am wondering if
these documents shed any light on the
CIA involvement in Tibet and on the GA
support for the khumba's in their
guerrilla fight against the Chinese sure
let me back up just a little bit in the
1950s Pakistan was America who's called
America's most allied Ally we actually
had more treaties of alliance with
Pakistan than we did with any other
country in the world Pakistan was a
member of the central treaty
organization was a member of the
Southeast Asia Treaty Organization we
were firmly in bed with the Pakistan's
the Eisenhower administration liked
Pakistan because it was clearly with us
in the Cold War whereas India was a much
more neutral posture the CIA as a result
developed a very close relationship with
its Pakistani counterpart in the 1950s
one of these relationships was the
famous you to a YouTube aircraft were
based in Peshawar in Pakistan that's
where they took off to fly over the
Soviet Union that's where the the famous
mission they were shot down began in
1959 there was a second secret operation
and that was to support the Tibetan
resistance in 1950 China moved troops
into Tibet the story of whether Tibet is
part of China or not part of China you
can go to the to a library there are
bookshelves full of books arguing both
sides of it I'm not gonna go into that
today from the Tibetan standpoint it was
pretty clear-cut their country was
invaded by the Chinese their way of life
was attacked by China in many ways and
their spiritual leader the Dalai Lama
was forced into exile or went into exile
what few people know is that when the
Dalai Lama went into exile
there was a CIA team of trained Tibetans
that held
to get out of Tibet and cross over the
border into India where he remains to
this day the CIA was also providing
military support to Tibetan rebels
fighting against the Communist army the
People's Liberation Army and that
support was provided from an airbase in
Pakistan in what is today
Bangladesh what at the time was East
Pakistan if you think about the
geography where can you get at to that
easily from Bangladesh or East Pakistan
is placed very close by the CIA trained
some of the operatives in the United
States some of them were trained at the
CIA's training facility in Camp Perry in
Virginia but most of them were trained
in Colorado and the logic of that was
that Colorado is as close to Tibet in
terms of geography in climate as you can
find anywhere in the United States I
don't know whether that's really true or
not but that was the logic they were
trained at a at a US Army facility that
had been used to keep captured German
soldiers in World War two they were
trained there they were then flown to
East Pakistan and then parachuted into
Tibet in many ways it was a crazy
operation there was no possible way the
Tibetans with all the Americans support
in the world we're going to actually
defeat the Chinese People's Liberation
Army John Kenneth Galbraith thought the
whole idea was was crazy even called it
unsanitary not sure that why exactly he
picked that but it's one of his
arguments the operation continued after
the Eisenhower administration into the
Kennedy administration the documents
that I alluded to about the relationship
between arrow and Kennedy don't speak to
it very much officially the Indians were
out of the loop I'm increasingly
convinced that the Indians must have
been aware of at least part of what was
going on after all there immediately
next door but they were they were not
involved
the operation at this point but we do
have fortunately two very very good
accounts of the operation written by CIA
officers who were involved in it and who
got their memoirs published cleared by
the CIA's review process which provide a
very very in-depth report on what was
going on just to go back to take you
back to Mountain Vernon for one more
minute the business between Kennedy and
Ayub Khan that night was top secret high
Yukon the month before the Mount Vernon
Senate had turned off use of the air
force base in East Pakistan he wanted to
send Kennedy a message if you want to
flirt with the Indians if you want to
give India economic assistance it's
gonna cost you something he didn't want
to do this in public he didn't want to
have a public falling-out so the easiest
way to send the message was to cut off a
covert program the Americans would know
the rest of the world wouldn't
necessarily know it wouldn't become a
big issue Kennedy at that dinner that
night in addition to a lot of Senators
and cabinet members also invited the
director of Central Intelligence Allen
Dulles and when everyone else was having
their mint juleps and orange juice
before dinner Kennedy took Ayub Khan for
a walk in the gardens around Mount
Vernon and asked him would you let us
continue the operation to fight the
Communist Chinese would you resume use
of the Tibet pace and either because of
the charm of the night or the charm of
the president or maybe because he always
intended to he agreed to and resumed the
assistance resumed that operation now
flash forward to Averell Harriman when
Averill Harriman arrives in India he has
three items on his agenda one is a
political agenda how to work between
India and Pakistan second is a military
agenda how much more military assistance
to get to the Indians what kind of
assistance what kind of joint training
operations to
we pursue and a covert agenda because
now that China and India had gone to war
the CIA and the White House judged the
Indians were ready to replace the
Pakistanis and they were right and the
Indians now began to support the Tibetan
resistance and CIA flights now started
coming out of India to drop equipment to
the Chinese the other thing that began
was u2 flights heretofore YouTube
flights had only come out of Pakistan in
1963 in 1964
YouTube YouTube flights now to come out
secretly from air bases in India and it
was one of those air flights from a
Indian facility that discovered that the
Chinese were in the final stages of
preparing to test their first nuclear
weapon and gave the United States the
crucial intelligence that China was on
the verge of becoming a nuclear weapons
State
only other thing I'd like to share just
say a word about the ambassador in New
Delhi John Kenneth Galbraith because
he's a huge part of this book John
Kenneth Galbraith was a tall man six
foot six he was born in Ontario in
Canada he's a graduate of the Ontario
school of agriculture
he then moved to the United States
became an economist wrote several books
in the 1940s and 1950s about economics
and became one of the stars of Harvard
University one of if not the star of
Harvard University in the 1950s and he
also became an advisor to Kennedy he
wrote he kept a diary while he was
ambassador to New Delhi and he later
published that diary for historian of
course the diary is gold because it's
not a memoir a memoir is written later
and you put in how brilliant you were
whether or not you were or not a diary
you write at the time and you may still
say you were brilliant but at least we
know you actually said that on the 19th
of November 1962 or otherwise the diary
is a fascinating piece of very
unpolitical and politically unaware
politically unknown dialogue he writes
his impressions of everybody and
everything the State Department for
example he constantly criticizes he says
working with the State Department is
like fornicating through a mattress he
also talks about people and he has a
very 1960s attitude towards gender for
example he describes flying from
Washington to Hawaii with a American
movie actress at the time and in the
diary says I fell in love before we even
took off and the magic of this voyage
you have to wonder what did his wife
think when she read his diary years
later but it also provides an enormous
amount of in
nation about what the Indians were
thinking what they were up to how the
United States government worked how the
Kennedy administration worked the inside
workings of the kennedy administration
by somebody who wasn't sitting in the
White House but had a very different
optic sitting in New Delhi watching what
was going on in the White House and one
of the things that really appalled John
Kenneth Galbraith was he could see the
Kennedy administration sliding into the
Vietnam War and he kept writing the
president saying don't do it don't do it
don't listen to the generals all the
generals are going to get you into a
mess and it's an interesting question of
course another one of the great what-ifs
of the Kennedy administration if Kennedy
had lived would the United States have
gone into the Vietnam War
the way that it tragically did under the
Johnson administration so that's another
perspective that I think you'll find in
this book that you don't find anywhere
else thank you thank you very much for
coming thank you